hello and welcome to maths my file
the effects of coronavirus across the
world are unprecedented
it has entire countries on lockdown
millions of people quarantined in their
homes world economies are crashing major
tech companies calling of events and
instructing employees to work from home
administrative failure was seen in many
countries and let's not even talk about
the status of a health care system not
enough manpower not enough equipment not
enough infrastructure is a story of
almost every nation right now this is
what happens when a pandemic of this
scale strikes multiple nations with
populations of millions but only having
a handful of ventilators now we've made
a video on coronavirus pandemic on 5th
March 2020 and these were the stars of
the pandemic on that date and look at
the Stars on 27th April 2020 in just 45
days 1.8 million new cases have emerged
and unfortunately more than 200,000
people have lost their lives let me
pause for a moment and give you time to
grasp this information the unprecedented
data shows you the gravity of the
situation we are currently facing many
more are losing the fight against
guarana every day and the world is
grasping for help however there is an
ordinary side to the reality also
although coronavirus has wrecked the
human species the rest of the
environment is blooming the animals and
the birds are back in the cities mother
nature is reclaiming her earth so in
this video we will look at some of the
developments that have taken place in
the past few weeks and also what future
possibilities this pandemic holds for us
as Homo sapiens let's first look at the
worse affected countries by this
pandemic and how different countries
responded to this situation the country
leading the charge today is United
States of America with over 24,000
deaths and over 600,000 cases USA is
receiving more than 26,000 new cases
every day and more than 1500 deaths each
day for the past few days
u.s. is soon followed by Spain with over
170 thousand cases and 17,000 756 deaths
among the countries that showed a good
pandemic prepared
included countries like South Korea and
Singapore in the months following
China's first reports of the virus South
Korea kept its numbers of cases low just
30 infections had been recorded when on
February 18 a woman reported to a
hospital in Daegu the country's
fourth-largest city it became clear that
this woman who has been named as patient
31 was a member of a religious sect
there was several news of her attending
church services and a buffet lunch
despite having high fever she had been
ill for some time and had repeatedly
ignored pleas to be tested the Korean
Centre for Disease Control and
Prevention quickly announced that out of
the nine thousand three hundred people
who attended church services alongside
patient 31 1,200 were now complaining of
flu-like symptoms hundreds of tests
positive in coming days following this
event in just 10 days
cases left above 5,000 yet South Korea
who was headed towards the same
direction of countries like Italy and
Spain controlled the spread of the
epidemic and as of April 27 it only has
a total of 11,000 cases
and 250 deaths the backbone of Korean
success has been mass indiscriminate
testing followed by rigorous contact
tracing and the quarantine of anyone the
carrier has in come into contact with as
of April 27 the country has conducted
more than 600 thousand tests the highest
per capita in the world the UK and the
US have conducted a lot less than that
this shows us that even the most
developed countries in the world like
USA and European continent failed to
control the pandemic due to inefficient
policies of the governments and the lack
of preparedness of the health systems
while small countries like South Korea
Hong Kong and Singapore were relatively
successful due to the quick and timely
intervention that was need of the moment
one of the main impacts of coronavirus
outbreak has been a significant drop in
air pollution in many parts of the world
most notably seen in the developed or
developing industrial nations like China
and Central Europe the drop shows just
how much industrial activity has been
decreased here is a satellite imagery
from NASA and European Space Agency you
can see the level of ozone depletion of
our planet especially in the year 2011
and here is the latest image released by
NASA and you can clearly see that the
size of ozone depletion has decreased
significantly this is mainly because
industrial production has decreased
which implies lesser wastage and less
damage to environment less resources are
being exploited less harm is being done
to animals and subsequently less
pollution which is healing the ozone
layer
this pandemic turned out to be the best
thing for water canals of Venice where
the normal cloudy canals are clear
enough to see even the fish swimming
below New York's air index has gotten
cleaner Delhi's air pollution index has
come down to a healthy level for the
first time in decades now before I jump
onto the vaccine about coronavirus I
just want to mention that you can
support our channel on patreon.com
for a really low price that will help us
to improve the quality of these videos
by hiring more illustrators and
animators all links are in the
description bar below
researchers worldwide are working
overtime to develop experimental but
potentially life-saving vaccines this is
a great sign for the world over 35
companies such as NOAA acts Madonna
Biocon are actively involved in the
process of clinical trials for the
vaccine of coronavirus President Trump
at a meeting at White House on 2nd March
pressed for a vaccine to be ready by the
US election of November 2020 this has
led to a widespread confusion among the
people because many scientists and
vaccine experts like analyst Phil de
Smith who is a professor of infectious
disease at London School of Hygiene and
Tropical Medicine stated that I don't
think this vaccine will be ready before
18 months and this figure of 18 months
is based on the premise that there will
be no problems encountered in the
process the pandemic will be probably
peaked and declined before a vaccine is
available she added a vaccine could
still save many lives especially if the
virus has possible seasonal outbreaks
given that covet 19 is a newly
discovered virus and was only recently
found to infect people there is no
specific treatment for it says
infectious disease expert a mesh adelgid
who is MD at the John Hopkins Center for
Health security however there are
certain things that doctors have been
doing to offer protective care
these include isolation of the patient's
proper diet and fluid intake of the
patients assisted breathing in forms of
ventilators and ECMO for patients who
cannot breathe due to severe pneumonia
many drugs are on the watch list for
probable treatment of covert 19
these include hydroxychloroquine
azithromycin REM Daz aware and many
antivirals that were previously been
used for AIDS and SARS but sufficient
evidence that any of these drugs will
actually work is yet not available more
than one-quarter of the world's total
population is now confined to their
homes as government set up curbs on
movements and social contact in a bid to
contain the virus in many parts of the
world borders are closed airports hotels
and businesses are shut and schools are
getting cancelled these unprecedented
measures are tearing at the social
fabric of some societies and disrupting
many economies resulting in mass job
losses and raising the specter of
widespread hunger
much remains uncertain but analysts say
that the pandemic and the measures we
had taken to save ourselves could
permanently change the ways in which we
live work work ship and play in the
future in the post pandemic world
technology will be as ubiquitous as it
is now if not more and tech companies
will become even more powerful and
dominant that includes smaller firms
like zoom and bigger players like Google
Apple Facebook and PayPal and not just
American firms but also Chinese but as
the pandemic increases our dependence on
technology people will forget that
hostility towards a Silicon Valley at
least in the short term we could also
see more government use of surveillance
equipments this will be a useful weapon
to fight the virus
for instance countries like Israel are
using smartphones to figure out who's
been where in order to track clusters or
virus let's talk about the role of
robots in coronavirus from preparing
meals at hospitals doubling up as
waiters in restaurants spraying
disinfectants through vending rise and
dispensing hand sanitizers robots were
on the front line to prevent the damage
of coronavirus in many hospitals robots
were also performing diagnosis and
conducting thermal imaging covert 19
will fast-forward the fourth Industrial
Revolution and digitalization of all
services including public services now
let's see the effect of corona virus on
healthcare system we haven't faced a
public health emergency of this scale in
a century it is exacting a massive
psychological toll on the world's
population both physically as well as
mentally and there are bound to be calls
for action people across the globe will
use covert 19 as a strong justification
to demand universal health care and deep
bodies like whu-oh and CDC will be
questioned
we could also see government boost their
ability to deploy ICU level assets build
up stockpiles of protective gear and
ventilators scale-up hospital
infrastructure of emergency nature and
rely more heavily on military to fight
the disease
digital technologies will become even
more prominent and we are likely to see
a rise in the use of telemedicine as
well as home testing
I'll end this video with a quote from a
famous author there are so many things
in this world we cannot control like
earthquakes floods and pandemics but
it's important to remember the things we
can like forgiveness second chances our
relationships and our mind
it's important to stay mentally healthy
and physically fit at this point of time
so that your immune system can fight off
any infection that comes your way watch
our video series on the topic of
structure of immune system and how you
can improve your immunity naturally
thank you so much for watching this
video I hope you liked this one see you
in the next one